warren buffett is the ceo of berkshire
hathaway and is considered by many to be
the most successful investor in the
world he went from delivering papers and
owning pinball machines to becoming
known as the wizard of omaha
with a net worth of over 71 billion
dollars
need motivation watch top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best warren buffett and my take on his
top 10 rules for success enjoy okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
find your passion you're lucky in life
if you can find your passion i tell the
students you know what
you may have to take a job or two you
got you got to eat
but never give up searching for the job
that's your passion
try to find the job that you would have
if you were independently rich
that's the job i have and when you find
that job the job that causes you
to be excited every day and forget about
the pain
uh and where you associate with people
you love doing what you love
it doesn't get any better than that my
partner charlie is 89 and we were
talking about that this weekend you know
i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
and you know it how can it be any better
and
just cost of living does not equate the
standard of living and the standard of
living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money as i i
love to ride around in a private plate i
will
totally acknowledge that leave it
leaving that out you know i basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i can live on
easily live on a hundred thousand
dollars a year
and and it and i wouldn't live i
wouldn't live better
if i had eight houses if i hadn't you
know a 400-foot yacht or anything of the
sword
i've been on 400-foot yachts and i've
been a lot of fancy houses
but i'm in a house that i bought 55
years ago
it's warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer
it has everything i wanted plus it has
all kinds of good memories you know
my kids have good thoughts about it i
can't imagine
living any better i paid thirty one
thousand five hundred dollars for it i
could pay 31 million
for a house and and it wouldn't it
wouldn't do for me what this present
house does
rule number two have the right heroes
the most
important thing uh
aside from the things i've talked about
already is it's really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are
i mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents
they're going to have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices as
you go down the line and you
who you who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important
for most people in terms of that
decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business but the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that's
better than you are
and then he or she and you hope they
don't figure it out too fast
rule number three be lovable when you
get to my age you will not measure
how well you've done by how much money
you've got i can guarantee you that
you'll you'll all do fine on money
anyway i mean
uh you know think about it seven hours a
day
you know you're in a bed you've got
exactly the same mattress i've got if
you don't listen
to it the furniture mark you know i mean
so so that when we're on a parody i
can't i can't outdo you you know in
terms of my sleeping enjoyment you can
you can match it by by buying this
mattress which we'll give you a special
price on just mention my name
uh we eat at the same places you know
we eat a dairy queen particularly if
you're in my position because we own it
but
but we eat at mcdonald's and burger king
and and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place
so our eating experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a 10
year old car up till about a year ago
you know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it
you know we dress more or less the same
i mean i pay more for my clothes but
they look cheap when i put them on so
we're really we're on a parody yeah so
so the money isn't going to be that big
a deal everybody in this country is
going to you know that
with the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean
you know so i won't i don't want i'm not
short changing it i'm just saying you
can't do
too much about that but you will measure
your success in life
by whether by how many and extent
whether it's the people you want at 70
or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end
i mean you can't you know you can't buy
love i mean it doesn't work you buy sex
you can buy testimonial dinners you can
buy your name on buildings you can do
all kinds of things
but the you know the only way you get to
be you know love is to be lovable
it's kind of irritating actually you've
got a lot of money be more fun to just
write out a check for a million dollars
so everybody you know from now on loves
me but it doesn't work that way
and in fact it the only way is to be is
to be lovable and and you know i've got
this friend
who uh who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and what is it now it's uh
60 years later you know she still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself in
determining who she really trusts his
friends
the one question in their mind is would
they hide me
now when you get to be 70 if you've got
a lot of people that would hide you
you've had a successful life i know
people who have a tremendous amount of
money
no one would hide their own kids
wouldn't hide them i mean
they they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know they they don't have anybody's
respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something of this sort but they
they nobody loves them and uh
my friend tom murphy at camp cities tv i
mean
dozens of people would hide murph you
know all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know that uh
ben graham a lot of people would have my
my dad it would have had a number
and then like i say that i can i can
tell you people
that uh you know everybody may pay
homage to them and
the kids may put up with them and hope
they don't change their will or
something but
the truth is that nobody would hide them
and if you've got a lot of people that
would hide you
when you get to be 70
you will have a very successful life
rule number four invest in yourself
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that
for example communication skills i tell
the students that come that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and
in person they increase their value at
least 50 percent and now i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark
nothing happens you know basically and
and you have to be able to get
get both your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course
some people wish i'd taken a shorter
course now in terms of my talking later
on
but it it's just hugely important and
you if you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you also if
you want to have more self-love and
learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below
but if you ask me to write a story on
what is potomac electric power worth or
something like that
i can write the story and that's what
i'm doing every day i'm assigning myself
a story and then i go
out and if i ever write a book it's
going to be called why smart people do
dumb things
if i give them a whole bunch of money
and they love the money and they don't
love the business
no matter what they tell me six months
from now they'll be gone rule number
five
learn the principles everything you do
learn is cumulative i mean
that doesn't mean that industries stay
good forever or businesses stay good
forever but
but learning to think about business
models what i learned at 20 is useful to
me now what i learned at 25 is useful to
me now and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes dramatically in terms of the
underlying principles it's like physics
i mean there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager
you know if you know what makes a a good
product
uh and you learn that in one business
you can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and uh i don't think i can win every
game you know
somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chess
so i don't play bobby fischer chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and
and learning what you're good at and
what you're not good at rule number six
have integrity all of you in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well on life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it
you get your full potential or do you
get 100 horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room
if you did have a lack of education if
you didn't have a chance to get a decent
education in life
it wouldn't make any difference what
that potential was because you'd never
unlock it
but the second most important thing and
equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we hire people we look for three
qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence
and we look for energy but if they don't
have the first one integrity
the other two will kill you because if
you're hiring somebody without integrity
you really want to be dumb and lazy
don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart and energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity
but the nice thing about
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump
or the color of your hair very easily
but you can
elect to have integrity that matches
anybody else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have
uh you will get an extraordinary result
and you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part go
unused
rule number seven take care of yourself
i do tell them
those students you know that if i gave
you a car and it'd be the only car
you're getting the rest of your life
you take care of it like you can't
believe any scratch you'd fix that
moment you read the owner's manual you
keep a garage and do all these things
and
you get exactly one mind of one and one
body in this world and
and you can't start taking care of it
when you're 50 by that time you'll rush
it out if you haven't done anything so
you you should really make sure that you
just remember that you just got one mind
and body to get through life with and to
do the most with it
rule number eight recognize your
mistakes one of the things you do
in your annual report which has become a
classic
is you will discuss what went wrong
like dexter and what you and how and
and and what you learned from it tough
tough to do well it's it's it's very
important to recognize mistake i mean
if if something but it goes around and
says you know i never made a mistake i
mean
you quit listening to them i mean you
know they're in the dream world so
so facing up to it uh
it it's it's a little like in in in
terms of discussing issues
you should be able to discuss the other
fellows position just as well as you can
discuss your own so i mean that's part
of thinking well and
and certainly part of making good
decisions in business
is recognizing the poor decisions you've
made and and
why they were poor and and that doesn't
mean you never do the same thing i mean
because sometimes it was a freak
situation but
but i have made lots of mistakes i'm
going to make more mistakes
uh but you know papers struck out a lot
of times i mean
it's the name of the game that you do it
you don't want to expect perfection in
yourself
you want to strive to do your best but
but it's too demanding to expect
perfection in yourself and it does some
good to recognize them and not start
trying to go around kidding people about
them rule number nine learn to
understand people
what other habits did you cultivate in
your 20s and your 30s that you now see
as being foundational to your success as
a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i i i really read a lot and
and i aspired to learn everything that i
could about the subject
so intellectually i knew a lot i did not
know a lot about human behavior i mean
that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
you
or you could be given 10 of the future
earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now are you going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height no anything no
no you're gonna you're gonna pick the
person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and
when you look at all of the qualities
that you admire in other people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper
who is the person that you admire the
most or like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then say
which of these can i do myself and the
truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you dislike that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you should get rid of those and it's
it's a pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is avoid credit cards as a general
matters of one piece of specific finance
financial advice i would say
you know avoid credit cards just forget
about them
we're in various businesses that issue
credit cards the american public loves
credit cards but if you start revolving
debt on credit cards you're going to be
paying
18 or 20 percent and you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20
over time you know if you can find
anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the
expenses roll in but but those were my
tools to work with but it was only
because i was ahead of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying 18 or 20 percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so
the trick i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there
you know and uh and that's true in
financial matters as well you want to
figure out where you don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems and there are two reasons why
they have terrible problems
one is a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and and really only society
can solve that one
uh uh in terms of protecting people
against that
that's just plain bad luck but the other
one is from people who run up
credit card debt and they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better it's way easier to stay
out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and i will guarantee you if you run
a big credit card that
you will be in trouble uh probably the
rest of your life
in terms of uh your financial situation
on the other hand if you get ahead of
the game uh
even it's on a very modest scale so that
money is coming in from investing and
you're you're
you people owe you money or equities owe
you ownership
uh you'll be way ahead of the game
compared to paying it
being always being paying your creditors
every month
so my advice to you is if you can't pay
for it
don't buy it now i've got a special
bonus tip from warren buffett on how you
can
learn to communicate that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know where do you
need to better invest in yourself let me
know put it down in the comments below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching i want to
celebrate you because believe nation we
don't just watch videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're going to
take action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you i was
terrified for example
both in high school and college i don't
know when it started
but i became terrified of public
speaking and uh
i just couldn't do it i mean i and so i
arranged all of my classes so i never
had to
do any public speaking and i got to
colombia
and i saw an ad in the paper uh for dale
carnegie course
and i went down it was somewhere in the
mid 40s and i gave the guy a check for
100
and i went back and stopped payment i
lost my nerve and then i came out
i got out of columbia actually when i
was 20 and i came out to start selling
securities in omaha
and i realized i had to get up and be
able to get up in front of people i
couldn't go through life this way so
i saw an ad again in the uh local paper
that there was a dale carnegie course
being given
i went down and i gave the fellow 100 in
cash and
i became associated with 30 other people
in the class we couldn't stand up in
front of a group and say our own name i
mean it was
we were it was pathetic but that class
changed my life in a big way
as a matter of fact they used to give a
pencil every week for whoever did the
most with what they learned the previous
week
and during that class i proposed to my
wife and she accepted and i won the
pencil that week
so it it's important i mean there's
certain you've got to be able to
communicate in life
and it's enormously important and
probably the schools
to some extent underemphasize that i
mean you can start going for an mba and
people think it's kind of beneath them
to teach
about communication but if you if you
can't
communicate if you can't talk to other
people and get across your ideas or
write you know
you know you you're giving up your
potential and uh you know
anybody that's got a career potential of
x i i guarantee it'll be 150
of x if they uh if they really learn how
to communicate well so that was
that was a big a part of really
succeeding in my career
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there